taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds hey taste
buddies welcome to
t-a-s-t-e
butts
good to see you
and the uh the chant lives on channel
always goes on
it goes on and on as you can see
everybody we're still friends yes oh
this has been some heated everybody's
been real heated uh everyone got upset
because we were talking about vices and
and we we focus on a lot of negative
things we need weed workers alcohol i
also just want to reiterate this is a
free podcast of two guys sitting on a
couch just arguing about nothing on
purpose
everybody who's taking it so god damn
seriously calm down they don't want to
fight you
we don't want to fight each other for
the most part um
we don't want you to get offended this
is we're trying to entertain for an hour
here yeah it's just you don't have to
take care of me as law and then write us
off if i don't like a drinker he doesn't
like marijuana uh poor people let's be
fair i got a lot more writing off than
you got yeah but i got to writing off in
pool verse beach okay all right fair
enough
you plant this little thing and you tell
them how to think and you you make this
little the little quip of you have
access
to i'm some rich guy or something like
that which is so funny wait i planted it
yeah you'll say like you you every once
in a while you'll give me a little uh
poke about like oh you you're you're
rich and famous
but i'm so not really rich and famous
like i don't know
people know me and i have nice savings
but but i'm not that guy at all like
people like sal thinks because he they
hopped on your thing was like sal thinks
people have access to private pools i'm
like no like i i didn't even have a pool
growing up i've never had to pull my
whole life i know but you played
my family didn't have money or anything
but i still found my way to a pool you
steered hard though into the private
pool uh enjoyment and also into the
percentage of americans that pools in
their yards
that was that was the way you two it's a
new day
[Laughter]
you shall be happy to know today we veer
back into the food realm yes the food
round or maybe you shouldn't be happy to
know we're hoping that you like the new
uh all over the place taste buds but
like i said it'll be still peppered with
food yeah food today it's gonna be pop
tarts versus
english muffins as you saw in the title
and i have yet
another chant to add for us
after going in hard after what happened
where there was a little actual anger in
the show yeah yeah here's what happens
frustration here's what we're gonna do
right after we say
right before we say the battle chant
what's the valentine again
b-a-t-t-l-e buds there's no pause no
pause right
right before we do the battle champ
we're gonna do this ready
come here i don't know if enough people
like the chance to like put him on a
shirt or something i have a fight you
got to put the mic
up just do it like this
what am i doing i'm unlocking arms
no it's fine nobody no only you would
care okay all right he's the audio guy i
know but only you would care right here
i am confused i know here come here do
this with me all right i come closer to
you yeah slide up put my mic down you
can put it down this will this will get
so cut go like this
no just do this with me right so before
we shoot the battle right
we do this did you
look at this i thought it was the other
day we lock arms like this and we just
go three times ago no matter what
happens i love you
oh my gosh
it's like oh my god
it's good
[Laughter]
affirmation therapy
no matter what happens i love you no
matter what happens i love you no matter
what happens i love you
and then into the all right here we go b
yeah
i will say that doing that ahead of time
actually does diffuse and dissolve i'm
telling you it works
it works you know man that's funny
oh my god they're just
i've been doing it in my head for the
last week
[Music]
every time i do it
he's walking the streets he's walking
the streets the lower east side no
matter what happens i love you no matter
what happens i love you
i was thinking it in my head and every
time i thought of it i was like i was
like
i was like i couldn't be like
we don't know where it frames the
battles we don't know we don't know
what's gonna happen and where we're
gonna net out on the other end of this
so let's
it's so funny it's like two literally
middle-aged men it's like all right
we're about to fight english muffin
versus pop-tart no matter what happens
no matter what happens i love you
no matter what that was i love you
because it's potential on the other side
of that for us to never talk again i
mean i thought that's how intense it
gets that's how tense it gets and i felt
bad that i said i don't love you after
the pool beach argument i felt bad about
that i was carrying a lot of guilt
i was carrying a lot of guilt about that
and let's not forget
people people a lot of the audience is
acting as if the only time it's ever
gotten like nasty and heated was like
was pot
alcohol weed whatever that's what truth
is yeah that's not true if you remember
the doritos episode was the one where my
mom called me and said i thought you two
were gonna hit each other yes and what
about the goddamn girl scout
yeah
so
oh no we've gotten way heated there was
even more than that i mean we've really
mixed it up so that's it so it's that's
a little thing to keep us on track
people by the way are already
already firing into the comments are
they already
i looked up oh should we should we just
see what early
early phones say i would love to
pop-tarts are tasty but you can pop a
guy with an english muffin i don't get
that but it sounds kind of funny
pop-tarts are probably the most
overrated breakfast suit of all time all
right
pop-tarts
pop-tarts bro
no way i'm pulling putting a dry bundle
of sawdust in my mouth at 7 am's i'm by
the way i'm teaming english muff today
babe yeah and i'm pop tarts
you got water on you from this yeah oh
okay all right if you choose english
muffin you must be over 80 years old and
have some sort of deadly disease
pop-tarts are a childhood treat english
muffin is what your grandma juni
i i got to be honest these are gen z's
they are wrong the best bread uh the
best pre-sliced package bread ever is
thomas's english muffin i'll stand by
that until the day i
you're going to give it hold on a second
i don't want to start the argument just
yet but you're going to give it best
bread ever
sliced bread available in the store if
you had to go one bread the rest of your
life that was english
for your sandwiches uh i don't care
really i'll take the english muffin wow
well all right i mean like yeah come on
let's be honest i mean maybe one other
bread for a sandwich but like but no if
i truly truly truly had to choose one
sliced bread off the shelf for the rest
of my life and every other one would be
eliminated i'm taking thomas english
muffins and thomas's people if you're
listening and we know that you are
call me
call me i love uh you know people are
saying 80 90. i'm 40 maybe i'm the young
new hip guy for your ad campaign
i love an english muffin especially the
raisin ones
um but i can't imagine if i if i was
faced with the choice of you only can
have this one bread i mean you got then
you're taking out bagels you're taking a
lot of stuff off the table i love
english muffins so much that when i bite
into one
even upon my first bite i already start
to get a little bit sad because i know
that i can't have the whole sleeve and
that it's going to be over soon
i mean like when i give it to you in
like a diner i'll tell you i ration i'll
eat like a bite of english muffin to
like 10 bites of food breakfast food
right back to the english muffin so that
the english muffin is like my treat
after eating the bread and then i close
with the english muffin i don't know
that i've ever ordered one where i have
an order too
wait well what i don't know that i've
ever ordered one where i haven't ordered
two
like i do right off the bat i got two
ingredients four slices yeah
can you go back to what that was pimp
what what the so the english muffin uh
what was that where would you have that
oh you had the the the uh
the history of the english muff didn't
you
there you go
uh
originally called a toaster crumpet
well that seems less appealing to me the
english muffin first called a toaster
crumpet was invented in 1894
by a british immigrant to new york
samuel beth thomas
immediately embraced as a more elegant
alternative to toast it was served at
fine hotels and ultimately became a
mainstay of american breakfast cuisine
well i am all in with sammy beth
thompson i do agree i do agree that it
is a more elegant toast
um i got to be honest
i think bagels are the most profane of
the toasts
you know the bagels are the most like
like unclassy of the toasts i think yeah
you know what i mean it's a big fat it's
almost like in a hoagie roll yeah yeah i
could see that you know bagel's a little
bit excessive
it's a little bit uh
accessible yeah it's loud it's a loud
it's a loud bread
but the i i do agree that the the
english muffin is the daintiest and and
uh and most elegant of the toad is there
is there an english muffin commercial
i bet you there is remember when we
looked up the jelly come you got in the
jelly yeah yeah the grey poupon
there's an english muffins commercial
like that too yeah there's gotta be
let's see what they are why have so many
of you switched from toast to thomas's
english muffins
definitely the granny it was the nooks
crannies look this doesn't have any
i forgot about nooks and crannies
how would you forget it it's their whole
image the way the crannies keep things
crispy
thomases the nooks and crannies muffins
much better than toad i will tell you
that was an effective ad campaign
because
everybody everybody just associates
nooks and crannies with with english
muffins yes uh nooks and crannies aren't
even relegated to food or bread
initially right right like they they
made nook and cranny in the form of the
topography of an open slice of uh
english they they connected those words
like people
in in food speak
they weren't saying like oh there's
nooks and crannies in this in this bread
if you like they they sign that i will
tell you this and for a hundred years
all i think about is nooks and crannies
to this day i don't know what a cranny
is i don't even know the differences
between i get a nook i don't know i
guess a cranny is like a little like uh
like a little uh like a nook
no no it's redundant no a nook is the
hole
the cranny is the
little crispy points
i thought a nook and a cranny were like
little pockets that uh
a small narrow space or opening well
then what the hell is the nook part i
think it's kind of the same like a
little little uh little cave
a corner or recess especially one
offering seclusion or security what's
weird is in that commercial they
specifically said the nooks something
along the lines right the nooks cap
catch the butter but the crannies keep
everything crisp or something like that
did they not say that
well if they didn't they're right they
differentiated between looks let me let
me and they they would say first of all
they're right like
i don't know another food that has nooks
and crannies and in the case of this
toast where they're hot where they're
hot and crispy and you're spreading
let's just call it butter as the number
one slot over it that butter melts and
then gets into those pockets and nooks
and crannies and it just kind of
percolates there until you bite it and
you get a beautiful
toasty crisp this is just strong you're
coming out trying to get those uh what's
on the bottom of the underside of those
english muffins the white uh cinnamon
semolina semolina right oh that that
makes for a crunchy crispy tasty treat
as well on the underside i will tell you
this in my life
i've made quite a few
uh english muffin pizzas it's called
farina well i know i i traditionally at
dolfarino is something different i guess
that's some type of farina the white
particles are freeing farina is a cereal
food frequently described as mild
tasting usually served warm made from
cereal grains used to prevent the dough
ball from sticking to the oven plate
right and also to give the product its
unique taste i mean we don't know what
nooks and crannies are we don't know
what farina is we're we're all over the
place with this english muffins i mean i
mean
at a diner when someone says you want a
toast or english muffin what do you say
uh it depends i do not turn down in
english
if there's raisin toast on the docket
then i might go raising toast now if
there's a raisin english muffin you know
how i feel about raisins take out
raisins let's just call it bear toast
versus english muffin yeah english
muffins 100 out of 100 yeah but it is i
only associate it with breakfast i was
going to say earlier i've i have made
jelly
now i would have said pizza well i was
going to say i i've made many an english
buff of pizza and during my childhood
um but i would never do that now i'm
that's you know what i'm not against it
i can't i don't think i've ever done it
i mean what are you thinking you got
butter you got jelly you got peanut
butter you got peanut butter and jelly
you got jelly and butter i don't know
what you got cream cheese and jelly
peanut butter and jelly to me it's it's
like white bread or go home like with
peanut butter you don't have peanut
butter and jelly on a toasted english
muffin now have you ever tried it
do you understand what happens i with
the nooks the crannies the peanut butter
and the jelly
no you don't even understand it's an
elevated experience i would want butter
and jelly on that english muffin toast
fine have you had done that
of course i've done that yeah what am i
butter and jelly steam yeah i i of
course
i i gotta be honest like
the people saying it's for old people i
have enjoyed english muffins from the
day that i had teeth
today sure but i do get why people think
it's for old people it does have an old
people vibe it comes in that they call
it
muffin well it's called an english
brother number one if it comes in a
coffin-esque box
[Laughter]
by the way
when you pull it out of the plastic it's
like you pull six people out of the mold
yeah yeah one of those yeah yeah
by the way it's it's it's the only bread
that i still know that is just still
thrown into the bag with the little clip
on it i mean no that clips everywhere i
love that clip yeah but but but like you
get like plastic a loaf of bread a lot
of the time now it's in the bag with the
clip but then you open the bag and then
there's it's still wrapped in plastic
yeah yeah english muffins they're still
just sliding them right in there they
they're great though because now they
got the whole grain they got the double
six-pack they got the large sandwich
english muffins have you tried those
i don't even know about it it's like the
size of half a frizz frisbee it's this
big it's an english muffin this big it's
made for full-size sandwiches you've
never thrown like a beautiful like like
a ham and cheese or a turkey and cheese
on an english muffin well i'll tell you
this i'll tell you what i've eaten a lot
of on an english muffin and you know
they're my spot and you know i defend
them to the death mcdonald's puts all
their breakfast sandwiches well
initially now they've branched out into
other i don't i won't get any of the
ones that aren't on the english muffin
but again i associate it with biscuits
breakfast i always go biscuits i don't
you know why the uh english muffins
again mcdonald's is brought up yet again
yeah that's what i'm saying they're
using english muffins at mcdonald's are
not
they're like a they're like their own
version
and they're just not toasted all these
muffins are fine but i really i really
like to plant my flag and thomas's
english muffins the english but the the
ones mcdonald's aren't toasted and
that's the problem oh there's another
version yeah you're right your heart's
when you're probably there's another
version of muffin that i got at trader
joe's i forget what it's called it's not
an english muffin and it's it's thicker
and it's more
sponge-like there's not a lot of nooks
and crannies but it's dense
and then i wish i knew it because we had
it like a couple of weeks ago and i was
like this is a this is a a noble entry
into the space all right all right uh
you got to try the full sandwich now
another thing that i didn't realize i wa
we're in the debate
we need to do the chant we we're we're
okay
we've talked by the way
about english muffins for how long we
have a whole episode 15 minutes you can
go on the pops i i gotta finish my thing
we gotta we gotta get down
to the pop tarts all right after this
all right go ahead all right but let's
start the show properly
[Laughter]
no matter what happens i love you no
matter what happens i love you no matter
what happens i love you all right here
we go b-a-t-t-l-e
buds okay
we should make a t-shirt that just says
that over and over happens i love you no
matter what happens i love you
we'll just do it i love it
i love it we need that extra piece of
merch we got it yeah that might be fun
that'd be a good go for the comments
that'd be a funny hat too no matter what
happens i love you
a cartoon are you two hugging each
embrace yeah that's that's great yeah
that's like an eighth grade dance what
we just did
i'll
yeah
to you
don't be funny is just a picture if you
don't see me or south's head just a
picture of the arms locked like that
that's that's all right let me just
shout out the muff one last time because
i worked at a restaurant for a cool
decade and uh besides my restaurant
there's a couple of places that are in
uh famous none of us famous for their
cheeseburgers and burgers here and i
gotta tell you we served our
cheeseburgers and burgers on english
muffins really and oh my god it's it's
my favorite way to have a burger really
really maybe a potato roll
you know i don't taste it you kind of
had it with the potato roll to be honest
yeah i really have it's enough already
nothing to me with a burger give me a
sesame seed you don't like just a
classic martin's potato roll on that i
don't dislike it i'm just tired of it
because everybody started doing it and
now every time and like sometimes you're
in the mood for it but if you don't want
a sweet flavor to the bun you don't i'm
not into it same with the brioche yeah
so all right well but i'm telling you
boo uh
you know what else i like everyone's
only a hundred cows
i do like that i do cut it in half still
50 on each side with your traditional
breads you're getting 100 120 calories
of slice but never mind the pop tart
all right you're just injecting poison
into your body
did you see how much positive i said
about your food the crack of dawn i said
i said so much positive about your food
okay now if you want to go in i'll go in
well i'm not a pop-tart guy i've had
pop-tarts in my life i will say i've had
a pop-tart in my life
maybe 10 times in my life it's usually
once every couple of years or whatever
it is i only really like the s'mores
versions i don't really love the fruit i
feel like it tastes processed i hate
this and i just can't get into
i can't get into that it's just hot and
sweet too early in the morning now i
know people eat those shits all day long
night night snacks i've never toasted my
pop-tart once in your life not what's my
most ways and i i'm equally unimpressed
i come out of the box
regular
i mean dude there's nothing like there's
nothing like having that statue of
pop-tarts up in the cupboard and you're
laying on the couch
and and it's let's say let's say it's a
9 30 10 p.m okay
you've had your dinner you're six eps
deeps into whatever you're binge
watching that week
and you go
oh i got pop-tarts yeah you go in
i'll keep two flavors on hand okay i'll
keep a blueberry or strawberry and then
always the mainstays the cinnamon
there's a cinnamon one that's unreal but
what's the filling
cinnamon it's like a cinnamon like
spread okay in the middle dude okay it's
delish okay it's like a frosted cinnamon
so and i'll go in and i'll get i'll get
one pack of the fruits and one pack of
the cinnamons and i'll just go
what are we talking about here
yeah and now you want to talk about sad
i get like that like you said with the
english muffins i got out of the
pop-tarts i started eating it and i'm
i'm like
i gotta i have to be doing something
while i eat this one will eat it too
fast you eat them in pears you always
eat the that's how you serve it that's
not because i don't think that's serving
size
what's that serving size is one two one
tart no two in a package two in an
individual sleeve i understand it comes
two in the sleeve what is the
recommended serving size in the back i
think you're eating two pop-tarts don't
quote me but i think you're putting down
360 calories in a serving approximately
400 calories for two strawberry frosted
pop-tarts but at the end of the day i
would say
let's see what comes in but you know at
the end of the day yeah but at the end
of the day i'd say if you offered me two
pop-tarts versus one donut because one
donut on average is about 375 calories
if you offered me two pop-tarts versus
one doughnut i would find the two
pop-tarts to be a more substantial and
fulfilling snack
i would agree unless it's some type of
crazy good like artisanal donut or
whatever but but you're not popping
donuts for snacks all the time are you
i'm not popping pop-tarts for snacks all
the times either what do there is no way
a donut with chocolate is 195 calories
all right you know what pimp look up
dunkin donuts maybe that's i'm thinking
of their calorie count
but uh but not nevertheless yeah it's
200 a tart
yeah yeah yeah i mean you're you're just
wine and bang you see the calorie count
on those dunkin donuts you got
individual donuts at four sep coming in
at 470 dude oh
i mean apple fritter is 5 10. i know but
the thing about this thing is dunkin
donuts has no place here right now but
my point is this is if i won dunkin
donut i it's never enough i need three
you're saying you're saying
those two
i could in theory be like okay that was
a good like little sweet treat let me
ask you as a pop-tart fan but i prefer
i prefer four you've eaten four
pop-tarts that's what i said i go in the
cupboard i get to get the fruit one in
the cinnamon one i thought you meant
you'd have one and one and then combine
them for a fruit cinnamon pack twice no
dude anybody that has ever put you've
eaten a single pop-tart back in that box
is a psycho who has closed up that fake
sweet yeah but don't you feel like
very very guilty after you finish that
second pop-tart babe my whole life is
guilt
i sat on here two weeks ago and defended
having 16 drinks in a night i mean what
are we talking about here i'd like to
know from our fans i talked about going
and sitting on sand by a lake yeah my
whole life is guilt yeah
yeah of course i feel guilty
in comparison
i i i do think though like how many
people like if you're a pop-tart fan in
the comments do you slam the door too
put it to you this way tell me in the
comments if you're a pop-tart fan
how hard it is how tempted you are to
break open a second package and eat
number three and four is that something
you always do you've done it and you
hide in shame or you fight the urge
every time because i feel like that's
just i feel like two is too much i feel
like i fee two
here's the thing
four of the same flavor
no way
two cinnamon and two fruit filled
it's a different ball game and it says
800 cows can i just i don't do the four
sugar i'm gonna do four often i'm just
saying you've got it i could definitely
shade it with two but sometimes it's a
four pop tart enough yeah i've had two
two muffs two english muffins yeah yeah
you know like someday look let's be
honest both of us can sit here and say
we've had our four doughnut nights
we know we have you know what i mean i
gotta imagine i don't know but i gotta i
don't know if i've eaten four doughnuts
but we've had our nights we've i'm sure
i've eaten worse than that but i just
don't know about it uh each one
so you're working on 96 grams of sugar
for those two packages that's a lot of
sugar listen we're not here to talk
health we're here to talk enjoyment and
flavor and i'm here to talk yeah but
yours is in comparison to my 100 calorie
no sugar treat well yeah if we're just
talking products also if you don't
slather yours in jelly and butter it
tastes like i fit into that desk over
here you're actually
full point actually what am i saying i'm
adding butter and jelly yeah and then
also too also too i give you that this
was a thing this was a classic thing
growing up with my friend jim and i
he would say this about his dad we were
talking about like gross things our dads
did yeah and i would go my dad will eat
hot dogs out of the pack he won't even
cook them because they're already cooked
my goodness so pull them out of the
package just eat it because because it's
already cooked
which but it's still disgusting yeah and
jim oh my god jim would trump that with
my dad eats english muffins raw and we
couldn't wrap our heads right in the
shop
his dad would just pull it out i've done
it i've done it i've done it i've done
it i've done it plenty of times it's not
a habit it's not the norm but in my life
of eating english muffins i've done it
plenty of times it's cray-cray sometimes
there was english muffins i didn't have
access to a toaster i just eat it i
don't care no butter or jelly just just
you eat like a doughnut i could put
butter and jelly on it but i don't know
that's i'm not asking you could you i'm
saying you have gone in i have with a
closed english muffin
because that to me i think i slice it
you should be institutionalized i think
anybody eating a close english muffin
whoever's not splitting it i mean it's
it's disturbing dude it's ah i could see
it i could see it
this i gotta be also the english muffin
you close your eyes it tastes like an
english muffin you actually taste the
variation i believe in the flavor of the
bread too of course i closed my eyes
that you think i'm not i don't know what
i'm eating a pop-tart no not just the
texture though i just mean like even
when it's like you chewed it i think the
english muffin has a different taste
than your regular bread i will tell you
nothing i want to ask you as a lifelong
pop-tart fan
are you not upset
with the icing ratio that has changed
over the years not at all i think it has
become better with a lesser icing ratio
i i didn't like cool things about the
icing
i disagree completely when i was a kid i
didn't like pop-tarts because of the
frosting on top it was too much it
overpowered the filling
now you are the lone child on earth that
thinks that i like the filling better
picture you
i picture you exactly but as a kid my
favorite thing glasses save here and be
like i'm going to tell you something
right now
this icing is not for me not for this
kid it's overpowering my filling my
favorite dessert as a kid and to this
day i'll still give it the number one
dessert of all time oh boy uh over over
next to chocolate cake of course it was
was the raspberry hold on hold on let me
tell you this before you don't move on
okay stay with me here wow i know i saw
stay with me
be professional yeah
my favorite dessert is a kid and to this
day it's a contender for my number one
can we guess it good
can you give us a little hint twist
that's the hint that's the hint twist
that's a huge hint dude
twist a crawler a french color dude it's
a soft serve
no twizzler it's in i'm honestly three
guesses i'm honestly hurt that you don't
know this out of how many times i've
brought this to events
a twist the raspberry twist from
entemins
the entenmann's raspberry twist it's
called oh okay okay i wasn't thinking
like that niche so so that's my favorite
and as a kid and i it as a child your
favorite was an entire raspberry twist
you know that was the that's like an
adult you're giving me [ __ ] for english
that was like what my grandparents said
my favorite dessert was something paulie
walnut
but this is my point
this is my point with the pop-tarts when
i would get a piece of it that didn't
have enough raspberry and it was a lot
of frosting it would piss me off
oh my god the frosting on those
those twists are the best
it was all about the raspberry for me
and the frosting is a compliment on the
right no the cheese the danish day the
danish to this day it's the raspberry oh
the cheese is the star of the day i
never cared about the like cake as a kid
i didn't like it heavy icing
he's i can see him at his birthday
parties like 20 kids 20 kids around the
kitchen table his mom walks out with a
danish candles you know what i do with a
danish
i would rip it apart just eat the middle
part
the middle part is gangbusters but
that's what i mean that that's that's
the center of the pop-tart is the jelly
part when i was little we used to go to
church and like in the back of the they
had the books that you could like the
church magazines the leaflets that you
like followed the mass along with and
had all the prayers and the things so
you could in the back of the pew like in
the seat there and you'd open it and
you'd finally be like turn the page blah
blah blah right and then you'd be like
say this psalm or this hymn right
there was always this thing in ours that
said danish amen mass
okay and i don't know
i don't know why it said danish amen
mass
to this day but it stuck with me and my
sister's name is dana one of my sisters
and i call her day then we started
calling a danish when we're little and
then we started calling her danish amen
masks as a full-on that was like heard
one of her nicknames in full for years
wow all right she's the walk in the room
be like danish a man mass wow all right
yeah all right danish amen what does
that mean
danish amen mass
dana sheamen no this is like a it's it's
uh
these are videos of the i guess the
ceremony
or maybe it's like the hymn or whatever
i don't know anyway go there go back to
so i am proud to say that pop-tarts have
now stepped into the realm that english
muffins did a while back as bread
for breakfast sandwich carl's jr
that's not a breakfast thing
says it says popped oh it's ice cream
sandwich i thought that was eggs look at
the picture i thought that was eggs it's
a scoop of vanilla ice cream but it was
eggs
oh okay i could see i gotta be honest
with you i'm not against the idea of
eggs between two strawberry pies oh my
god
that's grass
i try it
i take a bite of it oh i'd love to see
you try that
yeah
well i used to make breakfast sandwiches
with toast jelly the toast and put eggs
with the toast and jelly oh okay so i
don't know if i feel like i've been okay
i feel like it would be kind of similar
a dollar forty-nine you can get
that is less than the pop-tarts closed
at the store
yeah like if you get the single pack at
sev it's like two-fifths
oh that's so you break this is a hack
that carl carl's jr you want to do at
home you break that pop tart in half you
put a big keeping scoop of ice cream on
there and you make yourself a pop-tart
ice cream sandwich i see it's it's a
full pop-tart broken in half i thought
it was two full
tarts no oh not to deviate but we were
talking right before we started and hold
your thought there hold it right there
yeah we'll come right back to it but uh
we we had just done a hey babe and we
switched sets
signs
and i cleared out
uh two oil paintings we got from our
fans and we've even gotten more than
that and uh you were like what
we don't have any paintings and i said
well in the beginning of hey babe way in
the beginning chris and i were like
went on and on and about how funny would
it be if people made oil paintings with
us in old victorian garb and actually
sent us the paintings and of course the
fans are amazing we have many talented
people and they started coming in the
reason we don't have any is we've never
broached the subject so i wanted to take
a moment
to to to appeal to our listeners and say
hey all you people that draw very well
or have talent in the paints
okay so this is what i would like
oh i'm going to commission did you see
the burton or anything someone did i
love it it was amazing i love shout out
to whoever did the journey of us we
should put just post that right you know
and actually yeah can we if you're
watching now which i would i hope you
are
can we get a copy of that high
resolution i have okay great then we'll
have the burton i'd love to hang that up
here's what i want i want a picture yeah
i'm i commission you the fan i want a
turkey with your head on it like kramer
and seinfeld okay all right and then i
want
what can my head go on what's another
famous like your head is on
oh and then i want and then i want me as
i put you on a spit on a rock i want me
no no i want me as the girl in willy
wonka after she eats the blueberry gum
um what's her name uh
oh come on she's the best
yeah so i want me as baruch assault and
sal is the kramer turkey
i want somebody to make you holding
scooby doo but it's sal and you guys are
doing the chant i love you okay all
right all right you are you holding
scooby doo he shagged your scooby oh
okay all right that's great that's three
no that's two that's two paintings three
no because the blueberry and turkey can
go together they're the same yeah
yeah yeah yeah also if you just wanna
just send your own ideas too and then
your own ideas yeah all right we love it
get it go ahead all right so back to the
pop-tart i look man you know we haven't
even gotten into variety yet
that's the thing i we have so many nice
varieties we have the raisin we have the
whole grain we have the whole wheat we
have the sandwich size we have the
hundred cows
we have we have all this stuff i don't
even need to get those into the mix
these are gonna be a classic english
muffin i will put up against everything
you're gonna come at me you're gonna
come out of
my brand right at you that's got
blueberry strawberry apple cinnamon
there's blueberries
s'mores you pointed out you're gonna go
against that with multi-grain and whole
wheat
as your varieties i've said this before
nobody's picking the whole multigrain in
whole wheat over those white bread uh
english muffins unless they think it's a
dietary choice they have apple cinnamon
they have raisin and they also have they
also have blueberry which is delightful
it really is delightful okay pull up an
apple cinnamon english muffin i've never
seen such a thing i've never heard
cinnamon
folks we want to welcome a new sponsor
to the show canva pro
canva pro is a design platform that
empowers you to create and share
stunning content in just a few clicks
designing with canva pro is amazingly
fast and fun you choose from thousands
of templates that are easy to customize
or you can start from scratch you got
endless premium fonts photos videos so
much more that can add personality and
edge to whatever it is you're designing
okay yeah uh never been easier to design
right now sharing editing commenting in
real time it helps you stay organized
and on the same page team projects you
could do no more misplaced files or
tedious back and forth plus
you and four teammates can unlock
everything canva pro has to offer for
just 12.99 a month so if you're someone
who works and you're building your own
website or you have some type of graphic
user interface
canva pro is like a one-stop shop for
everything that you need all the tools
you might need to help design this thing
yeah you can get all your design needs
serviced at canva my favorite feature of
canva pro is the extensive uh library of
tools that are right at your fingertips
this is an example of so much technology
has gone bad this is example technology
going good i like that helping you make
your life easy and i like that you could
actually uh pause or like you could time
the posts of when they upload
automatically yeah so design like a pro
with canva pro right now you can get a
free
45-day extended trial when you use this
promo code you're gonna go to canva.me
tastebuds to get free 45 days of
extended trial that's c-a-n-v-a dot m-e
slash taste buds canva dot me slash
taste buds all right guys want to talk
to you about candid uh there's a
specialist for just about everything
right so when my car breaks down i go to
a mechanic when there's a problem i
shower i call the plumber
when you want to get your uneven crooked
teeth fixed you can see an orthodontist
they're the specialist and that's what
sets candid the invisible comfortable
and removable aligners above the rest
while poorly reviewed and insanely
priced clear aligner companies use
general dentists candid only works with
orthodontists and with candid the same
orthodontist who created your plan is
with you from start to finish so you
never have to wonder how you're doing if
it's working if you're doing everything
right you're covered the treatment is
prescribed and closely monitored
remotely by a licensed orthodontist
who's an expert in tooth movement
you can book an appointment at candid at
a candid studio near you or
do everything from home
gosh i love the future the average
candid treatment is just six months
you'll start seeing results way before
then and it costs
thousands less than traditional braces
with your aligner treatment you'll get
candid teeth whitening for free i'm
gonna see if they'll let me do this i'm
gonna investigate this i keep on
thinking i wanna do it
why wouldn't they let you you can do it
yeah i know i mean i'm just being candid
oh all right
candy can help you get the straighter
brighter smile you've always wanted
right now you can get started from home
for just 20 bucks with a candid starter
kit or you can book an appointment at a
candid studio near you today go to
candidco.com
tastebuds and use the code tastebuds
that's candid co.com taste buds code
taste buds take advantage of this
limited time offer for a 20 starter kit
candidco.com taste buds code tastebuds
cinnamon all right there's your cinnamon
plus protein doesn't that sound
delicious
uh and then there's uh
gotta be more than that blueberry
english muffins
oh there season right there go down
cinnamon cinnamon bun okay cinnamon
raisin i love the cinnamon raisin one
so they got they got they got flavors
pull up blueberry though pimp
i'll say this about both foods this is a
uh
oh boy
blueberry english muffins wow i've never
even seen oh yeah i see him i get him
and i enjoy him and i digest them and i
get him again i'll say this then about
both treats yeah
and this is a very pro for both sides of
this
i think both then do i didn't know about
these all these variation flavors of
english muffins i think both do a really
good job
with i'll say this i think both do a
really good job with offering a variety
of flavors i also think
that both do a good job of maintaining
their base flavor so with the english
muffin obviously it's the english muffin
you add blueberry you still have that
taste in english muffin but you're
getting some of that blueberry in there
too
pop-tarts the same thing strawberry and
blueberry pop-tart you still get the
pop-tart itself flavor which is a very
nice sort of cracker cake kind of flavor
for me i think that it lacks flavor of
the base of the pop-tart
i think it's chalky i think it's a
little bit like um
it's flaky not in the greatest way and i
think if you i think alone it really it
really lacks
zest
i said something really nice about your
thing yeah and you had an opportunity to
be a person
i'll tell you and meet me halfway and go
you know what you're right i i haven't
you couldn't do it because you're a
little little man i have enjoyed s'mores
pop-tarts and i have enjoyed pop-tarts
with chocolate filling and i've had them
toasted and not my point is i've only
had that like again a dozen times in my
life it's not a go-to snack for me i
don't like the fruit flavors here's why
i think that people or here's where i
the handle i pick it up from i've said
this before you could bring me to a
michelin star restaurant and have that
chef ring out his signature dish
next to it if you put fresh baked bread
with butter next to it i think that i
would long for both dishes equally
that's how much i love bread and butter
there was a time in my life that i
almost opened up a store
based on bread and butter
it would have failed i don't believe so
miserably i wrote out a whole business
plan and everything what would it have
sold it's going to sell all varieties of
different fresh baked breads and just
tons of varieties of artisanal butters
all right and it it was like they we had
coffee and tea but we also had like beer
and we had some spreads for the stuff
and basically it'd be like
you go in and get hot freight fresh hot
baked bread and butter but of many many
different varieties and combinations why
don't you do it that's actually a good
idea i i i don't know i mean i i wasn't
really going to start a bread and butter
but i i brought it up to a friend of
mine owns a restaurant too and because i
was like is this something can you run
with this and i'll like we'll do it
together i don't know but
i would if a place just served all sorts
of breads and butters and you go in and
be like mix and match and then sit down
and have like a even a pint of [ __ ]
beer with it right you know just like a
hot salty treat with a beer them like a
pretzel like kind of thing i don't know
i thought maybe it might work
i mean i think it's a pretty good uh i
think it's a pretty good idea but my
point is just that i i am that in favor
for bread and butter so for me
like
i don't i don't see pop-tarts for me in
my life they don't stand a chance
against one of the best combinations of
bread and butter the thomas is english
muffin i think uh i i don't think that's
a fair assessment you're you're because
without butter
your bread is nothing
without butter an english muffin is
nothing it has to have something added
to it but it shall and it will pop tart
is a pop-tart period yeah but i'm not
gonna say that like because it doesn't
come with butter i'm not gonna i mean
you're gonna apply whatever you want to
the english muffin but you pick a
pop-tart out of the case
or sleeve whatever the hell it's called
how about you're not sitting there going
it needs butter but well it doesn't i
mean it's bread joe how about that how
about the fact that you can spread
anything on the english muffin and make
it your own flavor you can go drive down
whatever street you want
i could just to me that's a beautiful
crunchy honey nut peanut butter on it to
me that's like arguing uh a baked potato
versus like uh a buffalo wing a hot wing
and you'd say well i could put anything
i want on the baked potato whereas the
buffalo wings flavor is its flavor it's
like yeah but that that's why i like it
two products
inherently different and they have to be
accepted at face value for their own
functionalities so i can't see me
needing butter as a downfall in this
argument because it that is the common
that is what you do well but i mean fair
fine fine but if but i
then would argue that there's no way
except for you because you have this
weird obsession with bread and butter
that you're on that you know your thing
is a breakfast thing as i've said
over and over oh i don't know about you
you get into it you get into a little i
told you we had it with burgers i have
it with lunch lunch foods i don't know
it was a midnight snack i don't know
anybody i could eat bread any time of
the day bread is not relegated to
breakfast no no an english muffin is
ready to relegate to breakfast
it's just not i don't know anybody
that's done the burger on the english
muffin i've never seen oh it's so good
i'm not saying it's not i've seen it all
i've seen i've been traveling
i'm just saying pop tart
it is it is one of my go-to's when i'm
on a road trip snacks
it is a morning snack
it is a late night dessert fun snack
it's just it's an all-day thing man it's
an all-day thing i think that you if
you're gonna if you are gonna take the w
here i think it's gonna be because that
is more of a dessert
and i think people like when comparing
two things that are really not in the
same camp because we the way we link
them were
you can
toast them and have them for breakfast
because when you brought up when you
brought up the challenge to me i said
i'm english muffin all the way you said
great because i'm pop tart all the way i
say but i don't see how they would and
you were right they both traditionally
are put in a toaster and had over
breakfast traditionally so that was
enough for me to go ahead but i think
people at large are going to be looking
at this and going well one's a piece of
bread and one is an actual dessert and
treat so well
i might lose that but i don't understand
these people right now being like it's
for old people because that's not that
wasn't the uh mo when we were younger
like i have nostalgia for english thomas
muffins just as how you or i would have
nostalgia for a pop tart pop-tarts are
getting slammed let's go to the phones
because we're we're we're uh we we
didn't even get to the phones
parts are the juggalos of breakfast food
i love that yeah that's very funny
dookie fly swatter
all i'm saying is i've never been on the
floor of a walmart begging for english
muffins to my mom very great porn i have
i have a very great point i have what
mom doesn't let her kid have english
muffins i think it was more of like uh
can we get these please you know
pop-tarts are basically drywall with
sugar flavoring i don't disagree
pop-tarts are too one-dimensional you
get your one math flavor that has a
thimble full amount of filling another
thing that's not true at all that that's
just not true no that's not that is true
that's not that is true maybe maybe not
with the true fillings but there's not a
symbol amount of fruit filling that's
sometimes you're disappointed from the
icing and sometimes joe you're
disappointed from the filling babe you
can't be disappointed for something
that's made with a computer in a factory
the same exact way every time don't talk
like the pop-tarts are a handmade item
and everyone that says you need to own
snowflakes but you think this is 100
percent consistency across the board i
have never actually said it i know it
i've never had a pop-tart where i
thought there was too little filling and
as i said i think the reduction in
frosting was a positive i stand by that
english muffin now
toast it with melted butter pbj english
muffin pizza so many this guy bugs me no
this guy's giving me my newborn friend
the way he wrote it english muffin comma
now
shut up max all right good girl you want
to read is the way that's supposed to be
read because i like the way i like the
time i did i like how he used his uh his
uh
punctuations and stuff i know you did
it's on your side welcome overland our
newest sponsor uh slippers slippers
family owned american heritage brand
that's been putting comfort and quality
first for nearly 50 years
overland offers outerwear accessories
and home decor made from
sustainable natural fibers like
sheepskin leather and wool man i got a
pair of slippers i love them
man it's i walk around this house i'm
feeling luxurious i feel like nanak of
the north it's so nice man they're so
nice they have to the wool in there and
the the oh my god and they're so like uh
they're like a slipper shoe yeah and i
just put them on and i just feel it's an
elevated in-house experience the warmth
they're using expert craftsmanship to
pair the highest quality merino
sheepskin which is naturally moisture
wicking uh temperature regulating and
anti-microbial
microbial microbial
this is the plot i was talking about
with supportive memory foam midsoles the
memory foam midsoles is the part i like
though in order to make slippers that
feel better and wear better for longer
something that really sets overland
apart is that they're one of the only
brands in the world that uses true
double-faced sheepskin i'm telling you
it's so comfortable what's my what's
microbial mean anti-mic
antimicrobial what does that mean
it's naturally like uh
it naturally fights like bacteria oh
that's good yeah all right
cause you know you're putting a slipper
on you're getting sweaty i never
expected my slippers to take that extra
step yeah michael well with overland
they do they're taking it all right
anyway don't wait another day to slip
into something way more comfortable get
the best highest quality sheepskin
slippers on the market at overland.com
taste buds you'll get free shipping and
free returns and i recommend you go
today because these slippers are so
beloved that they've been known to sell
out that's
overland.com tastebuds overland.com
taste buds
oh boy i love when meat shows up on my
doorstep that's why i come visit you
twice a week
we're talking about butcher box though
and that is a meat subscription mailer
that comes to your house but it's
freaking dope more beautiful set of
words than meat subscription
each box is 9 to 11 pounds of meat of
your choosing and it is top quality
stuff 100 grass-fed and finished beef
free-range organic chickees humanly
humanely roommates more humanly raised
pork what they do is they send the the
the pork to school and they dress it up
in an actual human clothes yeah humanely
raised
lobster tails wild caught alaskan salmon
sugar-free bacon we talked about butcher
boxes
i love sugar-free bacon that's hard to
find for some reason yeah i love that
they're doing yeah anyway we talk about
butcher box all the time on the show
okay um
they're offering ground beef for life so
they they also switch up their promo and
this time they're doing ground beef for
life and it's always amazing
for a limited time they're giving
members two pounds of free ground beef
in every order for the life of your
membership which is wild uh imagine
never having to shop a beef again it's
so true um the process is simple i
signed up i chose a box i chose how
often i wanted it they offer like
five boxes they offer four um pre-chosen
curated boxes and then you could do a
custom box so i like doing that one
because i like some items more than
other even though they're all good uh
butcher box ships you their order frozen
and it's always at the peak freshness uh
it's in 100 recyclable box shipping's
free i could keep everything i say it
just gets better and better it's great
uh you enjoy great tasting high quality
meat delivery right to your door okay so
we tell you we love it we use it that is
absolutely true uh i i made some tacos
last week with the the beef
and dynamite yeah my dad came over we
did a taco twos
i love a taco too and uh yeah just it's
just it's really good stuff you can't
beat it you can't beat it so don't waste
any more time go to butcherbox.com taste
buds you're gonna get two pounds of
ground beef free in every order for the
lifetime of your membership
again log on to butcherbox.com taste
buds and claim this deal
no no it just it read well it read well
the versatility of the english muffin
alone
mops the flow
with any pop-tart pop-tarts are for
children and derelicts
can you put bacon and egg and cheese
between two pop-tarts sure but it'd be
stupid and gross a bacon egg and cheese
on an english muffin cream cheese and
jelly come on fam dms that's my boy
cream cheese cream cheese in english
muffin is disgusting number one that's
oh my oh
i thought you're gonna get away with
this episode without getting heated uh
no it's gross cream cheese by the way
but that's an ass argument i can put
bacon on a english muffin but i can't do
it on a pop-tart okay
what is the point i don't understand the
versatility
you're pre-packaged by the way i said it
buddy you're coming off a factory
assembly line with the same exact amount
of filling and icing and you're
pre-packaged and you're ready to go the
english muffin is a blank canvas babe
well you're an english muffin and you
guess who i am
picasso i am i am
yes let's keep going here we do we have
any pro pop-tart comments here
um
let me keep looking for that they just
contribute
to artificial cancer
joe i hope your team pop-tart because i
don't want you to lose again thank you
isabella pop-tarts they
they make quick delicious breakfast food
but also for a quick snack on the go
with so many delicious favors absolutely
was initially thinking pop-tarts and
then thought it was an easy choice then
sat here for five minutes and really
contemplated it this is the beauty of
this show next thing you know i'm
thinking about what i'm doing with my
life and how i can be better the
match-up
kudos
there's our winner coach runner wins the
contest today you can follow coach
runner at what's
up
che is that c-h-e-y underscore okay
uh all right pimp let's see who won this
thing here we go wait do you got pumpkin
pie
drum roll plugs
percentages you got plugs or anything uh
yeah i got as of right now i just got 10
29 october 29th i will be at the durham
performing arts center with krista
stefano the deepak uh tickets are on
sale now they are going uh we'll we're
probably going to sell that one out so
get tickets right away and i am about to
announce a lot of uh extra dates for my
solo stuff but just not just yet but
savilecanoecomedy.comcano on socials god
bless you and uh
in november
i will be uh not with sal or chris but
with the other guy from no pro oh that's
right
[Laughter]
i'll be at sal and chris's show tearing
tickets
oh geez louise
how about how about october 29th when
we're over and deep in in durham north
carolina you're gonna be opening yeah
brand new new york city joey rose's uh
the establishment at 174 rivington in
new york new york is opening folks we
are get we are gaining speed on the on
the grand opening uh we are hoping it's
going to be october 31st halloween
weekend um i will keep you posted on
this show and elsewhere but please look
out for the information and the
announcements and everything but it's
coming it's crazy no that's going to be
lighting up it's creeping up screaming
fans of taste buds that visit new york
like when people come and visit and they
go
you know look at the seinfeld or sex in
the city locations or whatever fans of
taste was going to come to new york how
are they not going to stop by the
epicenter of it all
if they if
[Laughter]
it's going to be a tourist thing you
never know who you're going to see in
there i guarantee you i guarantee you
sometimes live episodes will break out
from from
absolutely it's coming it's coming soon
folks uh very soon uh all right here we
go ready uh can you do a is that a
refresher we have 12 000 votes is that
where we're at right now okay just about
12 000 votes just about oh lord i'm a
little nervous because i truly i truly
do you have any i i feel i can go either
way
i'm starting to think english muffins
are gonna take it from the comments it
feels like english muffins but i do
believe that people are gonna be like
younger people on social media number
one and i think that they're already
talking about it like it's an old thing
even though and i i do think people are
gonna be like oh dessert versus bread
i'll take the dessert right okay i don't
know we'll see but do you feel confident
or you can go either way
i don't feel confident right now but
i've been losing a lot lately so i don't
i don't know i don't feel confident but
i don't i i did going in but then the
comments i'm now i'm starting to doubt
it yeah i feel like i might lose all
right ready all right
it was a decent battle
56.2 percent to pop tarts
43.8 percent to english muffins after 12
000 votes
pop tarts will take that w
i
i'm just glad it wasn't a bigger bigger
win a loss there i feel like
that means there still was a good battle
it was a good matchup and i have enough
people out there thousands of people
that that agree with me i don't i don't
feel so sore about the loss i still love
you i love you too taste buds they
coming to the mic talking about the food
they hate talking about the food they
like two fools gonna fight but only one
food can be right taste buds man yeah
they're coming to the mic i'm talking
taste buds